I'm so happy to be here.
Well, I will say you are bringing the color
with that insanely beautiful, bright marigold jacket.
Thank you.
I, this is where my artistic expression starts and stops.
I can do the whole outfit, but home, I need help.
And I moved into this new apartment
and I started with the kitchen and then the kids' bedrooms.
And then I left my bedroom pretty bland
and I got stuck and I just stopped there.
Do you mean that you pulled the typical mom thing
where you took care of everyone else
and then left yourself high and dry.
Everyone else, exactly.
I mean, between work, the kids, sometimes my husband,
I try to do it all and then
You're too busy.
Too busy.
I travel, the work I do, I travel the country,
some parts of the world.
You know, I do a lot of volunteering.
Tell everybody what you do
because I'm really in love with your story.
Well, I do, really economic justice is what I do.
My mission is to close the racial and gender wealth gap
and hopefully overturn and the eradicate poverty.
So I've worked.
(audience applauds)
Yes, please yes, yes, yes.
So I've worked with Hurricane Katrina victims,
Hurricane Sandy victims,
helping them find money to rebuild their homes
and go back home.
And I'm, I love the work that I do,
but sometimes I leave some parts of myself
not taken care of.
Well, you are just such an amazing person.
Thank you.
And you deserve someone to take care of you
the way you take care of everyone else.
Thank you, thank you.
So I got involved.
Oh.
I did.
I can't, I couldn't help myself.
I have a little message from your family, actually
that I'd like you to watch right now.
Go ahead.
Surprise mom.
We are working with Team Drew
to create a bedroom just for you, our queen.
You're such a good mom.
Thank you for all you done for this family.
You're amazing.
We love you.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Can you stand it?
So cute.
Oh my goodness.
So cute, thank you!
They've got you the way you've got them.
Thank you, yes.
You've inspired them
and set the tone, right?
That was special.
And you are so deserving of this.
So we wanted to transform your bedroom.
We wanna tackle that room
and we wanna put some color into it.
Get rid of the beige, kinda go for it.
Let's go for it.
All right.
Everything that you're about to see in this room,
I personally picked.
I worked with the design team here at the show.
Every single thing is going home with you.
So everything in this room is yours.
And we all put a lot of love into this.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Are you ready to see it?
I'm ready.
Oh my God.
I hope you like it.
All right, let's reveal.
I'm so nervous now.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Thank you.
Oh my gosh!
Oh, it's gorgeous.
So, what I started with is this
is actually a flower home wallpaper.
I designed this with my design partners,
but I didn't wanna do the whole room in it
so then I picked up the blue ground
and dragged that through the walls.
I went with more wood tones because I just thought,
how can we bring nature in?
So even things that are made from wood
actually give you that sense of the outdoors.
I went with a woven leather chair, because again,
I liked sort of the blue and brown tones
was what I was really inspired by.
I also brought these natural lamps in.
I kept thinking texture, woven.
We did the rug that sort of had more of like a 3D pop
so that it wasn't flat.
I wanted you to have a big mirror
so you could look at your fabulous outfit.
(audience applauds)
Yes, yes.
And then this is our favorite addition.
Now these are photographs actually
of the communities that you've helped.
And we added this gallery wall of pictures.
Beautiful.
That is New York City, the Jersey shore, New Orleans
and that is in honor of the work that you do
in an artistic way but also to remind you
of the incredible accomplishments you do for everybody else
and to stay inspired to be the person that you are.
Thank you so much.
This is so wonderful.
It is perfect.
And you know, I have blue in one room in a living room
so all of this is amazing.
And this, when I saw these photos, my heart just dropped.
I love it.
That was so, it is so perfect.
I thank you so much.
It was so perfect.
I'm so relieved.
So perfect.
That you like it
You think you and your husband will be happy?
I, we will, I'm excited.
I know he'll be excited.
He'll say, whatever you say so I love it.
We need, I've been wanting this wallpaper.
Again, one of my friends, they send it
and I'm like where do you buy it?
Where do you start?
I don't even know where to begin.
So you've done it already.
And I love navy and the earth tones.
It's just beautiful.
So I feel like this is also
gonna bring the rest of the house together.
It's beautiful.
I'm so, it is, you did it.
Yes you did.
I love it that one minute I'm like,
I'm so confident as a designer.
Now I'm like (retching sound).
It's gorgeous.
Do you like it?
It's perfect.
Okay, good.
It's perfect, it's perfect.
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)